at Xbox we've always believed in the
power of games to unite us all today
communities of gamers not only play
together they create together and watch
together a whole new genre of games has
emerged design for both the player and
the community and with mixer we're
innovating new features to make these
experiences even better this one's
special of all the games in this genre
here is one that the world is having as
much fun watching as they are playing
and I can tell you that includes many of
us a team Xbox the creative director of
player unknowns battlegrounds is a gamer
turned developer who designed this game
together with a passionate community
please welcome player unknown himself
Brendon Greene
[Applause]
thanks Phil good afternoon everyone
player on owns battlegrounds is a
multiplayer battle royale where you must
fight against a hundred other players to
be the last one standing our team's
focus is to bring the most complete
battle royale experience ever to console
and deliver a great experience across
all Xbox one devices our development is
truly community driven and we are much
of our success to everyone who's given
us feedback over the past year with over
three million PC players to date we
can't wait to bring player unknowns
battlegrounds exclusively to Xbox one
later this year with an update for Xbox
one X enhancements shipping with the
final version see you on the
battleground everyone exclusive
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]